this vehicle could mark a revolution in
the auto industry the world has seen kit
cars before but this one is billed as
being buildable in one hour the tabie is
set to hit the streets this spring lead
Evernote my friend Francisco Lu and I
came up with the idea many years ago we
wanted to bring something totally new to
the market car that was environmentally
friendly and low-cost making it
affordable for a lot of people the
canonical customers have a selection of
shot YZ 2 or 4 seater they can also
choose whether they want a fully
electric drivetrain a hybrid motor or an
internal combustion engine the
construction blueprints are posted
online for download making the data
public is part of the makers open-source
principle users are also invited to
suggest design improvements our
objective is to have the best engineers
in the world working on the car and use
their collective intelligence everyone
who likes the idea of the tabi and is
interested enough can contribute to the
development as a car online I'm William
Murray voyager it of course is america
OSB or open-source vehicle is not the
first company to use the internet as a
development lab Local Motors from the US
consulted the online community when
designing its very first
ha the rally fighter the all-terrain
beast was marketed in 2010 but failed to
take off with drivers the crowd-sourced
co-created rally fighter has sold just
16 units to date it came a few years
after the c7 brainchild of German
designer Bant mashaallah like the tabie
it's assembled by customers themselves
they've continued evolution via online
contributions it came unstuck when it
came to actually selling however
shifting just a dozen units we survey
the streets of Berlin to see what
chances that Abby has it's fun to
assemble and that gives you a different
connection to the car I mean um although
a message Suzanne about art its way we
already have a car that's big and safe I
think we'll stick with it your Hanna's
Huebner works for a future mobility
Institute he's seen plenty of trends
come and go and thinks the tabie has
potential the TV set smiles all that
fatty tabby is at the point where I can
order one and have the chassis delivered
at home then I have to work out what
frame I want to add that I have a degree
of protection from the elements to
investors global online availability
means I can have a completely different
body in Africa from the one and I would
have built for the freezing conditions
of Scandinavia most of them get as many
have Fiat the urban tabby is the road
going realization of the open-source
framework it's expected to get street
legal clearance in Europe this year and
costs six thousand euros and there are
already new ideas for enhancements on
the drawing board
is who beulah thinks the basic concept
behind the tabie could be the way of the
future tech our idea has been around
since the 1950s what makes it
interesting for the future is being able
to buy a smart VW Lupo or whatever is a
base vehicle and then adding components
you could adapt your vehicle to clear
snow or transport surfboards that's the
real potential the urban tabi giving a
whole new meaning to the concept of
convertible